yeah thanks for the lovely welcome and
thanks everybody for coming over
my name is anda and I work at future ice
Berlin future ice is a tech consultancy
with an emphasis on user centric design
the future ice also enables us to work
on the project that we really care about
through it's open source and social
impact complex program called spice
answering this question of does hate
sound the same in all languages is a
project that comes at the intersection
of two things that I deeply care about
first of all natural language processing
and data science for social good it's a
project that I've been working on for
the past two months both both at work
but mainly in my free time it's a
project that I care deeply about and
it's still ongoing and in no way meant
to be exhausting so what you can expect
from this talk is an overview of
analytic capabilities right now and its
shortcomings the blood sweat and tears
behind labeling my own hate speech
detection dataset what models are out
there for other languages than English
and where do we go from here to better
tackle hate speech detection so why this
topic of hate speech detection
well in 2018 in Romania referendum was
organized with the goal to define
redefine the family in the Constitution
the main goal of the referendum was to
limit the possibility in the future to
legalize same-sex marriage as an
immediate consequence social media and
particularly Facebook sparked with hate
speech
I was very toxic no matter the side you
were on Pro or against the referendum it
hurt me everyday to see the terrible
things people would say to each other
and I'm not even a target luckily I know
a thing or two about NLP so disable me
to take action as I started digging into
the research and what's possible
for these kind of problems I realized
that there's not even a Romanian dataset
nothing related to hate speech for
Romanian only some studies about
quantitatively measuring hate speech in
comments but nothing about how to
automatically detect it so this was not
going to be easy I made a plan to
collect data and to label it and I was
very excited to try out both the more
traditional and the newer approaches to
NLP that are out there
I've been following closely my Twitter
feed my ultimate source of information
on the latest libraries and research and
I was really curious how this new state
of the art models would work on a
language like Romanian all of this is
possible for due to a cool technique
called transfer learning as Rachael
Thomas says you no longer eat big data
to achieve good results
so what transfer learning enables us to
do is to train a model on a large scale
data set such as Wikipedia and then
apply it on our own specific tasks
because such a language model is now
able to understand concepts like grammar
syntax and semantics and can either be
fine-tuned on on a smaller target data
set or used as a feature extractor for
text representations which can then be
plugged in into our own classifiers but
it's not all glitter and gold and is
these a waterfall of state-of-the-art
models led to another problem which is
that these models are huge while the
researchers open source their code and
release the pre trained models it is not
possible for average people and average
labs to reproduce these models or to
produce anything comparable so the two
main issues are computational intensity
and difficult reproducibility but also
shallow language understanding so we
don't know how exactly what these models
learn they learn in a very different way
compared to us children would normally
hear a word in a few noisy contexts
before
they understand its meaning why these
models need to see length times in
context before they can grasp what it
means and of course being at the mercy
of these big players to release the
models that would fit our use cases is
not ideal and frankly it gets even worse
when we talk about other languages than
English models our data Hungary and
progress in NLP depends on readily
available resources for languages which
of course for English are abundant but
it is not the case for for other
languages out there there are around
6000 languages spoken around the world
and for Romanian the Wikipedia it's much
smaller compared to to the tool to
English but why focus on lower resource
languages when English is so widespread
[Music]
what happens is that your language
shapes the internet makes your
experience of the internet and your
internet the Internet is as big as your
language this DS so for because of this
machine translation of documents on the
web or being safe and not abused on the
Internet
is not available for all and this is
something that making sure that we have
good technology for underrepresented
languages minorities and dialects is a
must for example conversations around
local politics and news tend to happen
in local languages and this brings us
back to the use case of his pitch
detection in Romanian so his speech for
English is widely studied but what about
the other languages I went through for
to bring awareness and to observe the
conversation about this I went through
the following four phases in order to
define this better for Romanian the
first problem that I hit was when I
collected the data because I don't have
a Facebook account and I don't intend to
get what once anytime soon
so I got in touch with Professor Adam
Meza from Babbage boy University on
University in Romania who is also
interested in the topic of tackling hate
speech detection and he agreed to share
with me a dataset that he collected in
the days before and after the referendum
this dataset is made out of the first 25
comments per post from 13 Facebook news
pages and 3 Facebook groups so now that
I had some data I could go on and label
it my main tools for labeling this data
set were prodi-g and snorkel but I had
to go through a lot more steps before I
could finally get hands on to have good
enough labels let me take you through my
thought process so the first time I went
through the data it felt a lot like this
spelling and grammar' on social media
and particularly Facebook is just
horrendous it's just painful and it hurt
every part of my body to read those
comments but also I might say failed the
first few times I tried to manually
label this data because as I was reading
the comments I would sometimes label
label a comment as hate speech and then
the second time I would see it I would
have mixed feelings about it
so it was really hard to even be
consistent with myself when labeling
these comments so to do that I needed to
do a lot more research so I went back to
the roots I started looking into what
hate speech is and I like this
definition from Fortuna and Nunez which
says that hate speech is language that
attacks or diminishes that incites
violent or hate against groups based on
specific characteristics multiple types
of hate speech but for this dataset I
chose to focus mainly a speech based on
sexual orientation on the other hand my
dataset also had also other forms of
hate speech such as hate speech based on
race on ideology and religion but for
the first iteration of the data set I
chose to focus solely on homophobia
professor Radu Meza together with one of
his students noticed that in this
dataset hate speech tended to occur in
one of the following four contexts
either when there's a was a mention of
the minority or the actors involved in
the referendum when there was an urge to
action and violence or in general when
there was violent language or explicit
language present of course these four
contexts are biased towards the topic of
the referendum and for a different data
set there will be different but similar
context this also helped me with
defining better rules for identifying
hate speech and finally labeling without
guidelines didn't work so I had to
establish some more rigor rotation
guidelines for myself but I could go
through every time I had doubts about a
comment so basically I would label a
comment hateful if you do if it would
attack a group of people seek to silence
a group of people stereotyped a group of
people or just promote hate speech and
violent crime so now having all of this
established I could finally go on to my
labeling work love workflow first of all
I again manually labeled three hundred
and fifty comments then I used this
really cool library called snorkel to
write something called labeling
functions didn't think of labeling
functions as weak classifiers so for
example whenever there was a reference
to the family in my dataset such as yes
for the family or heterosexual family or
family formed by men and women it would
likely be a hateful comment and this is
what this function does if it encounters
one of these expressions then it would
label the comment is hateful and
otherwise it would just ignore it
I wrote sixteen of these labeling
functions and then snorkel enables
enables us to evaluate them on our gold
labels so under data set that I manually
labeled in the beginning so going back
to the example of the family there are
twenty-six comments that contain no
reference to the family in my data set
and out of which twenty were indeed
hateful and six were not this gives us
an accuracy of about 80% for the
weak classifier for it but if you have a
I aimed for sixth having sixty percent
accuracy for all all of my labeling
functions for example religion only had
an accuracy of fifty percent which means
that both hateful and not hateful
comments were talking about this which
men that is not a good feature to
differentiate between what is hate
speech and what is not the cool think
about snorkel is that it also tells you
the coverage so how many comments your
labeling function covers in your gold
label gold data set how much it overlaps
with other functions is also how much it
conflicts with other functions snorkel
enables you then to train something
called the label model using all of the
information before the coverage the
overlaps and a conflict and such a
labeling function learns how much weight
to give to each of the labeling chosen
labeling functions when deciding on a
final label for a comment after this
labeling model is trained which is very
fast I apply it on the data set and now
I have labels I went the extra step and
manually checked and corrected some of
the labels because I wanted to make sure
to get the hate-speech labels correct so
this resulted in 1500 label comments out
of which 280 are hateful after going
through all of these as you might guess
I came to the realization how hard
hands-on labeling is you hear this a lot
of time but you never really feel it
until it happens to you
and even though it was so hard it was
far from ideal so for my labeling
process I had only binary labels which
unfortunately are not nearly enough to
capture the complexity of hate speech
and being a single annotator I likely
introduced a lot of bias in my data set
on the other hand for an ideal labeling
process you would have multi-label
classification so a scale for hate
speech multiple annotators at least
between three and five which can measure
inter and intra rater agreement and
finally close collaboration with experts
in the field such as such as social
scientists linguists but because I
wanted to
if hate sounds the same in all languages
not just in Romanian and English I also
used some of the other available
datasets for hate speech so I had the
dataset in Portuguese Indonesian German
and English and what is interesting
about all of them is how different the
strategy to label these data cities
because they used experts and
non-experts they used the collected data
in different way there was no unified
way in which this data was collected and
only the German dataset had an active
approach to D biasing the data set when
it was collected finally we reach I
reached the training models face for
training the models I used a simple
feed-forward neural network where the
only thing that deferred is the way text
is represented opted for a Center
representation which consisted either of
a bag of or full word embeddings or
transformers approach basically what
happens is that if you have a sentence
like product is high-quality and durable
it is fed to one of these embedding
models which is one of the ones I
mentioned before which outputs a feature
vector which is which is the sentence
embedding the sentence representation
which is then fed to a classifier the
output the probability over the classes
[Music]
so to very briefly go over the methods
the first one is tf-idf which is which
is a statistical method it stands for a
term frequency time inverse document
frequency and what it does is that it
computes the way to the importance of
each word in the corpus so if a word
appears a lot of times then is probably
not a good feature to differentiate
between what is right and what is not
hate while on the other hand if it
appears more rare more emphasis should
be given to this word in this case the
sentences are represented by a vector
that has the dimensionality of the whole
dictionary so in my case I had five file
it sentence was represented by a sparse
vector of 5000 of with 500 5000
dimensions to do tf-idf I limit eyes I
use the spacing limit icers which were
quite good and kept the unique grams and
diagrams which appear at least twice
word embeddings assume that words which
occur in similar contexts have similar
meaning and they are a small and dense
they are small have small dimensionality
and they are dense compared to tf-idf
each word being represented by around by
a vector of 300 dimensions
the Google released the word Tuvok for
English and also the code so as you can
train your own worth of ahmed el for
other languages in english you either
have to do it yourself I like I did on
Wikipedia or search if somebody
somewhere did it for you the next one is
fast text which is very similar to word
to Veck and the main difference is the
way that is trained on sub word
information for example a word like a
pole is represented by the sum of
vectors of the engrams so groups of care
and six characters it helps with words
which are which were not in the original
training corpus but they are in your
data set so out of vocabulary words but
also with words which are rare which
will now have a better representation
because they are composed from these sub
word information the original fast text
implementation released the models in
153 languages to obtain sentence and
beddings from this we use a simple
element wise a real simple element wise
averaging there are other strategies but
for this project I think I chose the
average pulled the worth of a can fast
text then we have birth birth had high
scores broke the leaderboard basically
last year and it is trained with it is
very promising and it is trained with a
masking strategy so instead of trying to
predict the next word in a sequence some
words are masked and the end bird has to
predict the words based on the context
surrounding that word the multilingual
version of bird is trained on 104
languages on the basically the 104
biggest Wikipedia's out there
Salem is an enhance xlm is an
enhancement of birth what is does
different is that organization which
helps to have a bigger shared vocabulary
between the different languages
but also the fact that it's trained on
two parallel sentences at the same time
for example it's in the same sentence in
English and in French at the same time
so what happens that when the words are
masked the model needs to use the words
from the context from the other language
to understand what's happening in the
second sentence and this helps with
learning cross lingual features finally
we have laser which is which stands for
language agnostic sentence
representations it is it has a similar
architecture to birth but instead of
using the transformer active
architecture it just uses simple
bi-directional NS TMS and also what the
authors noticed is that when they
trained it or 93 languages it was able
to identify languages which have similar
characteristics and grouped them
together this is very useful because
languages which are lower resource are
are can benefit from the high resource
of languages that are similar to it so
here is a short summary of all the
methods involved in this project what is
important to notice is that both the
word embeddings have a unique
representation of words so they cannot
differentiate between apple the fruit
and apple the computer while burt laser
and xlm have contextual representations
so they understand polysemy so finally i
for the results i have the five datasets
the test the test set for the evaluation
has 58 comments and 210 50 not hate the
scores that you will see are the
averages over three runs and the metric
is f1 score because the dataset is
imbalanced and the baseline model is the
most simple model that would never be
able to find a hates be a hate comment
in the test set so if it would predict
that all of them are not hate it would
have a zero forty five f1 score so here
are the results
in Romanian impressively laser was the
best performing model while Burton
Wilbert multilingual Burton xlm were on
par it's surprising to see the tf-idf
performed so well compared to the other
models so this kind of illustrates the
bias that I that I likely put into the
data set because it likely learned the
rules that I used when I was labeling it
as forward to vacant fast X apparently
the extra feature of fast text of being
trained on sub word information didn't
seem to bring anything else to the table
to understand better what is happening I
did a quick error analysis I noticed
that for the for laser the best
performing model which had an f1 score
of 8 of 0.8 it classified correctly
mostly the text that the comments that
contain a reference to vote family
children future and so on but it
classified uncorrect li the reference to
politician or unexpected combination of
words on in general creative ways to
phrase strong language this again
reinforces my assumption that likely my
data set has a lot of bias in it on the
other non English data sets laser was
the best performing model and which is
also what I show in the plot here on the
left right but where to Vic fast x + TF
idea for in general very competitive
with each other while bert multilingual
and excel em were worse than tf-idf and
word embeddings on the other hand the
people who released byrne multilingual
and xlm recommend that they are not used
out of the box like I did here but they
are instead fine-tuned on your own earth
task and then evaluated but there is
also an English Tel Aviv love the models
increased a very big absolute increase
except for laser and it shows the
importance that the model is trained on
a lot of corpora and a lot of text of a
lot of language resources available out
there but what happens when I'm so what
happens when a more
trained from scratch on a language I
compared a multilingual bird to German
Burton English bird and they both
experienced an increase and the same for
xlm I complained compared xlm 102 xlm
German excellent English excellent and
but and in both cases we see a small -
not so small increase so where does this
word where does this leave us does hate
sound the same in all languages
truth be told from what I've seen so far
I don't know at least not yet this is
mainly because as we saw different
models understand hate very differently
while it seems that cross lingual
features as in laser are very useful and
in general shows show a good performance
directly out of the box it is not the
case for bird or 4 or 4 for xlm so
overall I think we need we it's really
hard right now to answer this question
and one of my next experiment is to
fine-tune one of the models on a big
corpus of Portuguese for example and
then evaluated in Romanian and see what
happens then but in order to really
effectively tackle this problem of hate
speech detection in Romanian and not
only we need to rally the whole
community we need to get together both
data scientists social linguists and
social scientists and linguists so that
we can all get together and more
effectively tackle hate speech detection
thank you
[Music]
the first github link is to the way I'd
occupy label my dataset and the second
one is to the framework where the models
are implemented it's in collaboration
with one of my co-workers and we built
on top of each other's work there yeah
and thank you very much that was
absolutely fascinating talk and we've
got about five minutes or so now for
questions and so are there any questions
from the audience and cool laughter
athletic hi since you said that the data
set you had it was horrific spelling and
grammar structure how can this identify
hate speech if it is like two opposing
statements like one one sentence saying
family should only be for man and woman
and the response for instance would be
just why is it only for what men man and
woman but the grammar is bad and there's
no question mark how could this sort of
distinguish that the one is hate speech
and the other isn't well I guess I guess
this is part of the challenge I think
stands classification and sarcasm are
also still in development
so being able to do this more accurately
I think there is no right answer to that
now and that's exactly the challenge
that we're facing right now when we're
trying to better identify what hate
speech is and what isn't I didn't tackle
this echo chamber effect at least not
yet
I'm still looking into it and the
research available to make sure that
something that contains a hate word or
something that so a word that occurs a
lot in context and is not hate for
example like like in your example men
and women is not necessarily hate but
the way it's put in the comment results
in hate so I'm still looking into better
ways to tackle this kind of echo chamber
effect and thank you if you've got a
question I would ask you to put your
hand up um now and we'll see you can
guarantee okay
thanks for the control I didn't
understand how do you go from the back
doors that were too vague for example
give to you to the actual classification
task so yeah so from so here we have the
word embeddings for each of the words in
the in the input sentence and then they
are averaged column wise and then this
one is fed to to a simple feed-forward
neural network which has one dense layer
dropout a sigmoid sigmoid activation and
finally a softmax layer and thank you I
think we've got one more question here
and then hopefully have time for one
more afterwards so good people put their
hands up now so I know where to go
afterwards then yeah hi thanks a lot for
the really cool presentation it's really
cool to see that we're making some good
progress in like language agnostic well
word embeddings and general like natural
language processing what I was wondering
is because like the the least language
agnostic part is usually the
pre-processing right the normalization
you talked about lemma ties Asian yeah
so I was just wondering is there like
Romanian language normalization
capability in Spacey or did you write
the lemma Tizer yourself for Romanian or
how do they work yeah so I didn't
investigate too deep into Spacey
but they have so what they have is
readily available lemma ties errs like
you said for Romanian they had it for
all of the languages here for Indonesian
for German for Portuguese and so on but
these limit icers function only on rules
and rules that that started our
crowdsource so they are not perfect and
I remain I went to Spacey NLP conference
this year in Berlin and they were
developing a neural approach for limit
Ising for Spanish there are also efforts
in that direction for these languages
that have a lot of inflections a lot of
forums for
the verbs to better to be better lemma
ties I not just brute well brute force
cut thanks I'm think we've got time for
just one more question perhaps on the
back thanks
I was surprised to see that the a
tf--idf vectors were working so well
especially if you have a lot of spelling
errors have you thought about maybe
adding LSI or Lda to maybe created
latent vector space and then use this as
features we have classifier I didn't do
that yet but that sounds like a really
good idea I think I will try it yeah I'm
great thank you very much and we've got
about five minute break now and before
the next speaker Tessa and so if you
need to change rooms please please do
you say
[Applause]